Hello Freak bitches.
And this thing is the same way.
If you got some food on the counter and it's four feet off the ground,
that fucking thing.
You leave the room for one second.
That food is gone.
They're just feral.
Yeah.
It was funny,
like my puppy was like that when he was little.
It's like a,
I was,
I mean that's how puppies are and I,
but I forgot cause I haven't had a puppy in awhile and uh,
I was uh,
eating and I put some food on his plate and he saw it.
He's like,
oh,
I want some of that.
They jumped up,
put his feet on the table,
leaned in and tried to it,
tried to bite it and got a piece of meat in his mouth and I was like,
hey fucker,
you can't know.
Like I got to teach him this.
Yeah,
because they don't know.
They feel like,
well the food's right there.
I get the food.
Yeah.
There it is.
It's right there.
He,
our neighbors,
we're having people over there were having a party and I was over there and they
had a husky,
a fucking bad ass Alaskan Husky and this thing was,
you know,
beyond puppy.
It was big and they had meatball,
Swedish meatballs,
like four platters of them were right out of the oven.
It's still fucking hot.
And they left the room and they came back and they were gone.
He ate all of them,
all the Swedish meatballs hot.
He didn't give a fuck.
He's like,
here's my chance.
You have a full belly or have a,
you know,
or burn,
burn your tongue and have a full bag or not,
no food and is an Irish party.
This wasn't like there's Swedish meatballs and there is a sausage now Irish,
this one fucking thing and now it's gone.
The Swedish speak was a dog.
Eat all the food.
Yeah.
Dot.
It's a weird relationship that humans have with dogs is,
you know,
a lot of people have dogs to sleep in their beds.
They come with you places.
They hop in the car and then then there's the assholes that have those emotional
support dogs.
Yeah.
What is,
what's the jury out on that still?
It's a fucking ridiculous part of modern 21st century life that we allow that
stupid shit.
I was in a fucking restaurant,
like a really nice restaurant.
This lady came in and she's a lady from real housewives.
She was one of those uh,
what's,
no,
not the show.
Desperate housewives.
She's a famous actress and want to say her name.
Very pretty lady.
She hit the skids though.
But anyway,
she's bringing,
brings in this fucking dog and people are looking at it like what?
It's a dog,
like a golden lab and a big dog and she brings his dog and it's just sitting
there eating and there's dogs on the floor where like you might drop a fry or
your fork and pick it up and wipe it off.
And his dogs assholes just rubbing on the ground right there.
I mean,
basically you have this,
this animal's Dick is like rubbing on the ground and rubbing on things and dirt
on its feet.
It's probably stepping in shit and had pled.
People have allergies to dogs.
Oh,
90% up there night.
100% yeah.
And it's somehow or another,
they can get a note from their doctor that says there are two fucking week to
exist without this dog with them.
24 hours a day.
Yeah.
It's an emotional support dog.
This a lot of comics that have them.
Yeah,
but it's a like a loophole.
Luck.
Natasha has one,
but she like openly admits it's a loophole,
so she can't bring the dog everywhere.
She's got a doctor's note.
Yeah.
It says she's soft.
I think is what's her name's has to be allies.
Eliza's.
Does she have it set up?
Yeah.
Like,
sure.
That thing doesn't leave her side.
Yeah.
She'll make you watch it though.
When she goes on stage here.
Hold this Greg.
What?
Yeah,
I know.
And the people finger it.
I loved.
I don't know.
A lot of people do,
and I saw it.
Here are the dog waits for her to go out.
It just takes a task near,
so it's running a sense he had presents.
Just literally runs backwards.
She's going to hear this to be so mad.
We're kidding.
Eli's uh,
we're kidding.
Don't call Elis and either get mad at that.
Okay.